Now that you feel you've gotten
good feedback on your app ideas,
you might find that one's
emerging as a clear winner or
you still might not be able to decide.
Either way,
it's a good idea to research and
vet multiple app ideas
before deciding on one.
You never know when you might run into
a dead end and not be able to continue.
In the next few nodes, we're going to
start thinking about UI elements and
web APIs and libraries to use, for each
of the three app ideas that you have.
Thinking through this for
each of them will help you have
a better rounded picture and
make a more informed decision when
you're ready to start development.
First, let's start thinking about UI.
The following series of questions will
help you start thinking about how users
might interact with your apps.